we all want of course to be happy but a
strange thing about being properly happy
is that it's a state that requires us to
learn and regularly practice a slightly
odd sounding related skill knowing how
to be sad
everyday a lot of stuff happens to us
which is in one way or another pretty
hurtful someone doesn't call someone
says no a project isn't going to work
out you'd think we'd then just
spontaneously feel sad for a bit and
that would be the end of it but that's
not it seems how many of us actually
work frequently our minds which are
squeamish by nature rigorously shut out
unfortunate negative feelings and go
into a state of what psychologists call
denial where difficult but true
information is refused access we may as
a result of burying our feelings develop
a number of symptoms we can't sleep
bits of our bodies start at which we
develop an addiction or there's another
option we become extremely surely not
happy as such but brittle and insistent
in a faith kind of upbeat nurse the sort
of happiness that can't tolerate any
sadness here's a couple then and Freya
there's a lot of sadness in Freya but
she's learned not to let any of it into
consciousness
so she's often extremely cheery and
rather bad at picking up on other
people's need to be sad let's watch a
little film about these people about
it's the weekend what should we do this
weekend party party what's that song
Friday Friday gotta get down on Friday
would you love that don't you know what
I think about the other day you're so
good at karaoke I love it we need you
karaoke Saturday night and I like the
way you move
I just know you're ticklish around to
here you can listen to little quips hmm
we need to be sympathetic the origins of
jolliness are pretty painful they're
often to do with having had a parent or
early caregiver who for one reason or
another couldn't tolerate problems or
any difficulties they were perhaps
depressed or otherwise fragile so quite
early on the manically jolly person got
into the role of being an upbeat
cheerleader not because they were but
because they had to be pain is of course
a horrible thing to feel but because it
is a part of our reality we need to have
the courage to allow it to work its way
properly through our system we need to
learn to feel the pain of our lives
authentically before it's Joy's can feel
real as well
pushing problems aside is deeply
tempting but our pleasures will only
feel authentic when we first given the
pain all the space it truly deserves in
our lives we love bringing you these
films if you want to help us to keep
bringing you thoughtful content please
consider supporting us by visiting our
shop at the link on your screen now
you